good morning believe nation today's
message is everyone makes mistakes over
to you Jacque fresco this is how you
learn I think I told some of you in the
past that sincere people believe man can
fly they build small wings and they the
guy jumped off the Eiffel Tower and he
died and his brother rode make wings
larger next time that's how you get
experience everybody makes mistakes or
nobody makes any mistakes the first guy
that full with nitroglycerin nitric acid
Lisbon the building disappeared so - the
guy his cousin wrote never fool wood
that stuff so there's only one way to
learn and that's no one makes mistakes
they try whatever they know if it
doesn't work it doesn't work doesn't
interesting message you know I don't
know that you need to kill yourself to
learn in some of those examples but I
think too many people are afraid of
making mistakes I think too many people
are living their life because they're
afraid of making even the smallest
mistake and that means you play your
life so safe that you don't ever go
after anything great along the path to
learning anything you make mistakes you
want to learn to ride a skateboard
you're gonna fall over a bunch of times
right or maybe learn a bicycle as we
probably all do you know when you first
started you fell right there you had
somebody guide you and hold you you're
trying to learn a language you're gonna
make grammatical mistakes you try to run
a business you're gonna make business
mistakes right whatever you do you
basically you base it on what you know
and the more you can model success the
more you can get an education where you
can get experience the more you can
learn from others great but also testing
things out for yourself
testing your assumptions going with what
you know and trying to build off of that
and part of entrepreneurship is creating
something that's never been created
before right either create a new product
create a new service create a new way of
dealing with customers creating a new
technology part of being an entrepreneur
that's the exciting stuff is creating
something that has never been
before and so if you're gonna do that
you're gonna make mistakes along the way
it's just gonna happen because it's
never been done before so there's nobody
to show you that path and so you're
gonna fall down and that's okay
and I think too many people make a
mistake and then they say I'm not going
to be successful I quit and the people
in their lives pointed them and say
hahaha you know I knew you couldn't do
it look at that big mistake that you
make and if you make mistake after
mistake that's a mistake eventually you
figure out a way to get it right and
every successful entrepreneur if you
look at their history has a whole bunch
of mistakes before they were able to
build something massively successful so
don't be afraid of mistakes don't make
it this big stigma against you I've made
tons of mistakes I can't remember how
many mistakes I made today in my
business tons of mistakes
that's okay you pick up you keep moving
on and from the mistakes you learn to be
more successful so the question of the
day I have for you guys today is I want
to know what's the biggest mistake
you've ever made leaving the comments
below I'm curious to find out I'm gonna
join the discussion thank you so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso